[Musik]
mit allen Mitteln neue Dimensionen im
Ukraine Krieg und damit einen guten
Abend liebe Zuschauer eine ganze Region
überflutet der Damm vermutlich gesprengt
von den Russen das sei eine neue
Dimension weiß schon der Kanzler zuletzt
hatten auch die Ukraine eine neue Phase
des Krieges eingeleitet mit Drohnen und
Angriffen auf russisches Grenzgebiet
nicht alle Unterstützer im Westen finden
das gut doch mittlerweile rollt offenbar
die ukrainische Offensive an und viele
hoffen auf einen Erfolg die Ukrainer
selbst ihr Präsident und die Verbündeten
im Westen zum Erfolg verdammt
Fragezeichen das wollen wir wissen von
diesen Gästen
der Parteivorsitzende von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen omidor
Sabine Adler langjährige Moskau
Korrespondentin
Klaus Kleber ZDF Journalist
der Militärexperte Christian Mölling
und die Politikwissenschaftlerin Liana
fix
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
die alle Gäste noch mal sehr herzlich
begrüßt einen Dammbruch experten hatten
ihn befürchtet die anderen sind
überrascht und entsetzt
Milliarden Kubikmeter Wasser
unzählige Häuser in der oblastraße
unbewohnbar direkt an der Front
die Rettungsarbeiten wurden heute sogar
durch Schüsse und Detonation behindert
[Musik]
vollgelaufene Häuser auch auf der
russisch besetzten Seite
die Ukraine beschuldigt Moskau die
Bewohner dort im Stich zu lassen
das ist ein weiteres absichtliches
Verbrechen Russlands nachdem der
Terroristen statt dieses Desaster
verursacht hat Katastrophe Moskau
wiederum macht die Ukraine
verantwortlich spricht von einem
Ablenkungsmanöver
dieser Sabotage hat wohl damit zu tun
dass ein Großangriff des ukrainischen
Militärs vor kurzem gescheitert ist
das ganze Ausmaß der Umweltkatastrophe
noch gar nicht abzuschätzen der Kanzler
sagt schon jetzt
deshalb ist das etwas das eine neue
Dimension hat Material Ermüdung
Raketeneinschlag absichtliche Sprengung
der letzte Beweis fehlt offenbar auch
den Amerikanern
wir ermitteln weiter was passiert ist
ich kann Ihnen derzeit keine schlüssige
Antwort geben
und das ist eine gute Gelegenheit gleich
nach Washington zu schalten zu Liana
fix-politik Wissenschaftlerin in einem
amerikanischen Think Tank spezialisiert
auf die Sicherheitspolitik und
transatlantische Beziehungen Frau fix
können Sie uns helfen warum die
US-Amerikaner noch so zögerlich sind mit
der Einschätzung und den Verursacher gar
nicht nennen wollen oder gibt es neue
Erkenntnisse
ja tatsächlich ist es so dass es bisher
noch keinen eindeutigen Beweis gibt den
man öffentlich präsentiert hat aber
hinter den Kulissen wird durchaus
darüber gesprochen so wurde zum Beispiel
US-Zeitungen aus Regierungskreisen
kommuniziert das ist Geheimdienst
Informationen gibt die auf Russland als
Verursacher hinweisen das heißt
insgesamt tendiert Washington dazu
Russland hinter diesem dammkollaps zu
sehen zum einen gibt es auch weitere
Hinweise dafür es ist etwas was wo die
Ukraine schon seit Monaten gegen gewarnt
hat dass dieser Damm vermiet ist eine
internationale Beobachtermission
gefordert hat es ist etwas was zu
russischen Kriegsführung passt und es
ist etwas was natürlich vom Zeitpunkt
her aus russischer Sicht sehr viel Sinn
macht die ukrainische gegen Offensive
ist gerade gestartet sie war sehr
erfolgreich bisher im Gegensatz zu dem
was der russische Regierung Sprecher
gesagt hat und es gibt auch
Augenzeugenberichte über Explosionen
Messungen darüber dass es wahrscheinlich
eine Explosion innerhalb des damals war
die Stadt gefunden hat das heißt im
Moment deuten alle Indizien auf Russland
hin aber es klingt von offizieller Seite
noch sehr distanziert ganz anders um mit
nuripur der Bundeskanzler der von einer
neuen Dimension des Krieges seitens
Putin sprach wusste der Bundeskanzler
der mehr hat er andere Erkenntnisse oder
sie es ist wie es beschrieben hat aus
meiner Sicht auch ob Olaf Scholz sagte
alles spricht dafür dass es die
russische Seite war es gibt formal drei
Möglichkeiten das waren die Ukraine
dafür spricht so ziemlich nichts
machbarkeitsfragen sind sehr sehr
deutlich die die motivationsfragen
sowieso dann ist es die russische Seite
oder es war irgendein Unfall oder wie
auch immer aber da muss man natürlich
sehen das war ein Damm unter der
Kontrolle der russischen Zeit und
dementsprechend haben sie dafür die
Verantwortung zu tragen für alles was
sie tun und dementsprechend stimme ich
dem Bundeskanzler sehr sehr zu das ist
der neue Dimension der Kriegsführung
alles spricht dafür dass der krabbel
dafür die Verantwortung sabine
adlerseinschätzung ist interessant zu
hören Kollegin von Deutschlandfunk vor
Adler auch die Wasserversorgung der Krim
ist in Gefahr die Russen haben auf zwei
Dritteln des russisch besetzten Gebietes
erhebliche Schäden
sie hätten sich damit tatsächlich sehr
selber beschädigt wenn sie so weit
vorausgedacht haben das ist ja noch die
große Frage oder ob sie wirklich nur
dieses kleine kleine nazil nämlich den
ukrainischen Gegenangriff abwehren zu
wollen im Blick hatten das was an folgen
jetzt auf die Ukraine zukommt ist so
verhängnisvoll ist so verheerend und das
sind ja auch Aufbauleistungen von der
Ukraine die damit eine mal weggespült
werden also wenn man sich das anschaut
es werden die Ackerböden weggeschwemmt
das heißt also nicht nur diese Ernte ist
vernichtet von diesem Jahr sondern
wahrscheinlich für so lange so viele
Jahre wie der Staudamm nicht neu
errichtet worden ist ein neues
Wasserkraftwerk installiert worden ist
das Kanalsystem wieder diese große große
Landwirtschaftsfläche versorgen kann und
das ganze das finde ich das Gerät ein
bisschen außer acht es ist wieder ein
Angriff auf die
Energieinfrastruktur denn das AKW in
saporisi kann nicht gekühlt werden weil
der Pegel oben im Stausee singt unten
dafür ist das Wasser dann zu viel und zu
hoch dann gibt es das Kohlekraftwerk was
auch ganz wichtig war neben dem
Kraftwerk in SAP und es gibt dann eben
das ein dass das Wasserkraftwerk selbst
dass die Russen ja schon sofort in
Betrieb also besetzt haben und die
Ukraine sich dann entschlossen haben
anders als im AKW dieses Kraftwerk wird
eine Energie mehr produziere nicht
unterrussischer Besatzung dieses
Kraftwerks das heißt also die Russen
konnten schalten und walten ohne
Rücksicht darauf dass er da in diesem
Wasserkraftwerk Energie produziert wird
es ist ein riesenschaden es ist ein
solcher Schaden ist unglaublich
Christian Mölling ist bei uns
Politikwissenschaftler und
Militärexperte Herr Mölling eine
Zerstörung des Dammes haben die Experten
erwartet und gar nicht
darin gar nicht eine große Überraschung
gesehen gab es dennoch etwas was sie
erstaunlich fanden als sie von der
Explosion hörten was der Zeitpunkt war
es die Dimension
die das Ausmaß der Verjährung also ich
glaube
natürlich hat man es zu zweit technische
Möglichkeit in Erwägung gezogen trotzdem
ist es das ist dann getan worden ist
natürlich etwas wo man sagen muss die
katastrophale Dimension war dann
sozusagen
absehbar und wir werden jetzt glaube ich
erst schrittweise nur die
die Bilder sehen was das konkret
bedeutet aber was das sozusagen im
Großen und Ganzen bedeutet war klar
deswegen hätte man wahrscheinlich
erhofft dass es lange dauert bis
irgendjemand diese Karte zieht und der
Zeitpunkt hat etwas überrascht denn die
die Großoffensive in dem Sinne und die
Möglichkeiten die man mit diesem
Staudamm gehabt hätte langfristig den
Unterlauf des Flusses nicht mehr
überquerbar zu machen
und kontrollierbar zu machen die hat man
sich im Grunde genommen durch diese
Sprengung deswegen gibt es doch einige
Thesen die sagen das ist entweder eine
versprühte versprühte Sprengung gewesen
und oder auch ein Loch entstanden dass
man in dieser Größe eigentlich gar nicht
haben wollte jetzt habe ich eine riesige
Welle und ich habe eine komplette
Veränderung zumindest der der regionalen
Gegebenheiten ich kann nicht sagen wann
das wieder querbar ist ob es überhaupt
und die Russen haben zwei Drittel dieses
Territoriums auch das russisch besetzt
ist voller Wasser das stimmt genau das
ist nicht ihr Land das ist u dieses Land
das hier untergegangen ist aus
russischer Sicht glaube ich ist
besonders traurig dass die Material
verloren haben und sie ja selber auch
das spricht dafür dass es am Ende dann
doch sozusagen überraschend für sie
selbst gekommen ist sie auch ihre
eigenen Leute und eigenes Material nicht
in Sicherheit gebracht haben das hätte
man ja erwartet gleichzeitig muss man
mittlerweile sagen wir können uns sicher
sein dass es eben keine Material
Ermüdung gewesen ist sondern dass es
eine Sprengung gewesen ist weil es
darüber dass das fotografische Daten
offensichtlich gibt die das ganz klar
liegen und dann kommt der Punkt hin um
eben gemacht hat man kann nicht einfach
in so einen Damm rein marschieren und
eine James bond-mäßig Granate
dahinschmeißen das muss lange
vorbereitet werden das kostet Stunden
und Tage wahrscheinlich also von daher
das ist ja planvoll gewesen und
wahrscheinlich wollte man jetzt zum
jetzigen Zeit und nicht sprechen sondern
sehr viel später sehr viel später und
sie würden auch tippen gegebenenfalls
gar nicht so fundamental und so groß
springen weil der Schaden eben so groß
ist und größer als eigentlich in
Anführungsstrichen militärisch sinnvoll
wäre dass man einfach sagen muss ja
Militärs lieben eigentlich die
Kontrollierbarkeit in der Situation und
das sozusagen die Dinge für sich zu
verändern in ihre Richtung das hier ist
nicht sehr kontrolliert was sie jetzt
hinten rausgekommen ist also von daher
spricht eigentlich vieles dafür dass das
in der Dimension wie wir es jetzt sehen
so nicht nicht tatsächlich passieren
sollte Klaus Kleber ist bei uns der
Bundeskanzler ich habe ihn schon zitiert
spricht von einer neuen Dimension des
Krieges den Putin führt gegen die
Ukraine von einem ökozid ist die Rede an
anderer Stelle sprach die
Außenministerin schon mal von einem
Zivilisationsbruch als es um die
Energieversorgung des Landes gegen mit
der Sprengung eines solchen Kraft
Staudammes ist das eines von vielen
weiteren Kriegsverbrechen oder hat es
wirklich diese neue Dimension es ist in
der Tat also die Umwelt praktisch als
Waffe zu benutzen
ist schon ungeheuerlich ich finde es
aber auch jetzt weil daraufhin die Rede
war aus amerikanischer Sicht eigentlich
ganz klug nicht die ersten zu sein die
sagen hurra wir wissen es waren die
Russen so völlig verbraucht sich auch so
ein bisschen der zellfaden die Russen
machen nur schlimmes und alles Gute was
passiert machen die Ukraine
da macht man sich nicht glaubwürdig wenn
man erkennbar nach wenigen Stunden etwas
aus der Hüfte geschossen sagt wir wissen
dass es die Russen waren trotzdem zählen
natürlich all die genannten Argumente
ich finde die die den Gedanken dass es
sozusagen aus der Hand
außer Kontrolle geraten ist eine sehr
gute Erklärung dafür dass der Schaden ja
ganz wesentlich auf der russischen Seite
passiert die die Verteidigungsstellung
die auf dem auf dem linken Ufer des
Japan von den Russen etabliert worden
waren mühsam die sind jetzt alle weg und
untergegangen viel Material ist kaputt
gegangen und Glaubwürdigkeit in der
Region verlieren sie auch weil die
Menschen natürlich sich irgendwann schon
denken werden wer es gewesen ist da ist
eine neue
Art von Waffe gezogen worden und
möglicherweise im Gesicht des Täters
explodiert
was die langfristigen Folgen sind werden
wir sehen denn es hilft natürlich auch
nicht der Idee die man erwartet hat dass
die ukrainischen Truppen just in dieser
Gegend unter Umständen den Durchbruch
dann machen könnten um um ihre
längerfristigen Ziele zu erreichen das
scheidet jetzt aus wir werden sehen wir
werden einige Pläne neu geschrieben
werden müssen das heißt auch Herr Müller
um das noch mal konkret nachzufragen das
Gebiet ist vermiet es ist sehr viel
Material militärisches Material
explosives Material unterwegs was
geschieht damit jetzt wenn man auf diese
russische Seite schaut
auch genau hinunter ja genau das wird
einfach mit gerissen und kommt dann
irgendwo zum zum Stehen und Sie wissen
nicht wo es liegt in welcher Tiefe es
liegt eine lange mühsame Phase haben
dass sie genommen zu entminen und auch
die Explosivstoffe dann wegzukriegen wir
haben parallel die Entwicklung der
solchen Gefahr die durch
Kadaver steigen würde das sind Friedhöfe
aufgespült worden also das heißt sie
haben ich glaube das kann man sich
wirklich hier nicht vorstellen was das
für einen Schrecken für für die Menschen
für die Ukraine auf dem russischen
Gebiet sitzt auf russisch besetzten
Gebiet sind auf Ukrainisch besetzt sind
das ist eine wirklich dramatische
Geschichte und wir sehen auch dass die
Russen ja nicht nur diesen staudam
zerstört haben sollen sie gerade dabei
sind noch weitere Leute immer in der
Region zu zerstören und das wenn man
sich auch nicht vorstellen Seper ist als
Stichwort schon gefallen Frau Adler
danach wollte ich fragen ist es nur eine
Frage der Zeit bis Putin auch dieses
Atomkraftwerk als eine neue Bombe nimmt
also dieses Atomkraftwerk ist ja von
Anfang an ein Drohmittel gewesen wir
wissen der Einmarsch am 24 Februar 2022
ver über Tschernobyl und das ist ja kein
Zufall gewesen also dieses Spiel mit der
Angst des Westens vor einer atomaren
Katastrophe das ist die ganze Zeit das
Kalkül von von Putin und natürlich hat
er das auch mit dieser
Staudamm Sprengung noch mal ins Gespräch
gebracht ich würde gerne auf einen
Aspekt noch hinweisen nämlich auf diesen
militärischen Aspekt warum eigentlich
also es wenn eine ukrainische
Gegenoffensive
gestartet wäre dann wäre sie eben ja gar
nicht über diesen Fluss gekommen denn
die Ukraine haben ja überhaupt nicht so
viele
Fahrzeuge und so weiter also dieses
übersetzen auf dieses russisch besetzte
Gebiet wäre jetzt jedenfalls nicht
möglich gewesen und was ich mir
vorstellen könnte was dahinter steckte
war dass Putin endlich Erfolge sehen
möchte es ist nicht umsonst das schon
gut zweimal innerhalb von wenigen Tagen
jetzt vor die Kameras getreten ist und
Erfolge vermeidet hat die wir nicht
nachprüfen können die auch nicht
sichtbar sind aber es ist also
möglicherweise auch ein Zeichen von
dieser unglaublichen zerstrittenen
militärstruktur dass die eine Hand und
ich weiß was die andere machte und sie
alle gegenseitig also irgendwie sich
über trumpfen wollen Stichwort pregorien
Stichwort die wagnertruppe das könnte
auch solch eine dünenion eventuell haben
und dann ist das eher eine
Verzweiflungstat denken sie als
vielleicht eines militärisch so wenig
Sinn macht wie sie sagen weil es ohnehin
eben einen sehr breit eine sehr breite
Stelle des Flusses ist vielleicht musste
da jemand wirklich ganz schnell Erfolge
produzieren und hat an nichts anderes
mehr gedacht und wirklich nur noch im
Tunnel geblickt sie würden sagen
kommt eben in diesen Akt einer
tatsächlich eine Zerstörungswut aus
lauter Hilflosigkeit oder fürchten sie
da eskaliert jemand und muss noch gar
nicht zu atomaren Waffen greifen weil er
noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten hat zu
eskalieren ich glaube das genau
letzteres von uns gelesen werden soll
ich ich glaube das ist gerade
beschrieben haben hier ist darum geht
wirklich
brachiale Symbole zu setzen die
Sprengung eines Darms ist ja nichts
neues das kennt man ja aus dem
Mittelalter das letzte Mal war es ein
ganz großes Thema auf dem Euphrat da gab
es nämlich einen Damm ein Staudamm der
sowieso alt war und belastet und der war
komplett von Isis wir schreiben jetzt
das Jahr 2016 und er wusste man auch
nicht was passiert diese Anleihen bei
der symbolischen Brutalität und Barbarei
von Isis ist ja auch nicht neu wir
hatten ja auch den Fall dass
beispielsweise in ukrainischer Krieg
gefangen davor laufende Kamera
enthauptet worden ist und er geht es
wirklich um unsere Öffentlichkeit da
geht es darum bei uns die Knöpfe der
Angst zu drücken damit wir immer wieder
in derselbe Grübeln kommen oh Gott was
machen die denn als nächstes das ist
natürlich Verzweiflung das ist natürlich
die Tatsache dass die überhaupt nicht
vorankommen und natürlich wissen wir das
gerade ein Land mit so vielen atomaren
Köpfen atomaren und so wenig
bewirksamkeit im
konventionellen Bereich natürlich auch
zur schlimmsten Waffe greifen kann aber
genau diese Angst sollen sich permanent
ein impfen zu lassen uns davon genau
nicht leben zu lassen das ist jetzt die
Aufgabe wie sehr fühlt Wladimir Putin
eben gerade dass er eigentlich immer
noch ein viel größeres her hat und eine
viel größere Quantität militärische
Quantität aus Feld bringen kann und in
die Luft bringen kann Klaus Kleber hat
eine bemerkenswerte Reportage zusammen
mit der Kollegin Angela Anderson gibt
produziert für das Zweite Deutsche
Fernsehen von Moskau über Washington
nach Peking und zurück gereist Putins
Tabubruch die neue Angst vor der Bombe
heißt diese Reportage Klaus und das ist
genau die Frage müssen wir weiter Angst
vor Putins Atomwaffen haben obwohl seine
Drohungen davor
eigentlich
folgenlos geblieben sind bisher ich
glaube dass das
Besondere an diesem Krieg ist in
atomarer Hinsicht ist nicht so sehr dass
wir jetzt in den nächsten Wochen mit dem
Einsatz einer Atombombe berechnen müssen
das hat sich gezeigt dass es sich lohnt
Atom Macht zu sein weil man in dieser
unter dem Schutzschirm der eigenen
Atomwaffen
konventionelle Kriege im Grunde so
brutal führen kann wie man möchte weil
niemand sich auch keine Atom macht auf
der anderen Seite sich mit dir anlegen
wird und was wir im Moment gerade
erleben ist ein großes Ring um die
Grenzen dieser Kalkulation wie weit kann
ein Putin das kann demnächst auch jemand
anders sein und sich darauf verlassen
solange er Atomwaffen hat wird ihm z.B
der Westen nicht entscheidend in die
Arme fallen und was wir jetzt erlebt
haben seit Beginn dieses des Krieges ist
dass der Westen immer stärker jetzt die
Grenzen austastet immer noch regiert von
der Angst wir dürfen es nicht so
ertreiben das Putin in die Enge
getrieben dann auf den roten Knopf
drückt das dürfen wir nicht aber wie wie
weit können wir gehen und ich beobachte
auch in der westlichen insbesondere in
der amerikanischen Diskussion im Moment
zu einer Art
Euphorie darüber wie weit man eigentlich
gehen kann ich meinen putin ist
militärisch im Moment eindeutig in der
schlechteren Lage und er hat bis jetzt
diese fürchterliche Karte nicht gezogen
und er hat übrigens auch aufgehört diese
Drohungen so sehr in den Raum zu stellen
und da ist ganz interessant weil man
schreibt auch das eine Äußerung der
US-amerikanischen Administration zu und
du hast in dieser Reportage die sie
übrigens in der ZDF Mediathek sehen
können unter anderem David Trails
interviewt der auch dazu noch mal etwas
sagte was tatsächlich vielleicht auch
die us-administrationen überzeugt hat
schauen Sie mal
das Putin mit dem Atom sehr belasselt
war für mich ein Zeichen der
Verzweiflung der Krieg lief nicht wie
erhofft da greift danach allem was den
Rest der Welt einschüchtern könnte
Europa und die Ukraine und siehe da die
Ukraine lässt sich nicht einschüchtern
nicht im geringsten da liegt die Ironie
der Geschichte für den Nationalstolz der
Ukraine hat niemand mehr getan als
Wladimir Putin
das war damals eine total interessant
abgeschriebene Sache
der Präsident selber hat das Wort
armaged online also der biblische
Untergang der Welt benutzt dann hat sein
national security Advisor Sex hat hat
gesagt die Antwort Amerikas müssen nicht
nuklear sein sie könne konventionell
sein falls Putin diesen fatalen Schritt
war und dann kam ein pensionierter
general selber eindeutig der berühmteste
general in Amerika ist kam und hat das
auch ausbruchstabiert und sagte wir
könnten uns zum Beispiel vorstellen nur
mal so gesagt dass wir sämtliche
russischen Truppen in der Ukraine
vernichten und die gesamte
Schwarzmeerflotte
Russlands das wären dann katastrophale
Folgen für Putin ohne dass wir zur
Atomwaffe greifen müssen um damit klar
zu machen die Schwelle ist für unsere
Amerikaner nicht so hoch wir finden
andere Möglichkeiten dich zu bestrafen
und das hat auch tatsächlich dafür
zugeführt dass dieses selbe Rasseln ich
glaube nicht mehr wiederholt worden ist
also jedenfalls nicht in der Schärfe wie
am Anfang ich denke die Sache wurde
tatsächlich auch in Moskau wieder zur
Seite gelegt auch damit zu tun
vielleicht können wir die anderen fix
noch mal fragen haben die US-Amerikaner
verfickt heute weniger Angst vor diesen
Drohungen das spielte natürlich in
vielen Monaten auch in vielen unserer
Sendungen eine Rolle wie viel
Zögerlichkeit unterwegs war wie viel
Zögerlichkeit nicht wird deutschen
Regierung sondern wie wir dann für
erfuhren auch der US-amerikanische
Regierung eben nicht sondern ganz
allmählich den Ukrainern immer mehr
Waffen zu geben einfach weil es eine
große Sorge und offensichtlich auch
Misstrauen gab
ja tatsächlich ist es so dass der
russische Präsident des Wladimir Putin
seine Karten eigentlich zu früh
verspielt hat er hat ja seit Beginn des
Krieges in verschiedenen Kontexten mit
einem Nuklearschlag gedroht implizit
oder explizit wo ziemlich klar war dass
das ein Bluff ist und die häufiger er
geblöft hat und jemand
öfter sich herausgestellt hat dass seine
Drohungen in einem Bluff waren desto
mehr ist auch die Position innerhalb der
beiden intenisation desto mehr hat sich
diese Position auch verändert so dass
wir jetzt z.B sehen dass weiter Jets
also Kampfflugzeuge für die Ukraine im
Spiel sind dass die beiden
Administration auch keine große überaus
besorgte Reaktion zeigt wenn die Ukraine
Drohne nach Russland schickt natürlich
gibt es noch weiterhin rote Linien die
gesehen werden aber ein weiterer Grund
dafür warum sozusagen die Sorge dafür
zurückgegangen ist es auch die Rolle
Chinas China ist reingekommen in diesen
Krieg mehr auf der Seite Russlands als
auf der Seite des Westens natürlich aber
es hat sich positioniert mit einer
Ablehnung von russischen nukleardrungen
und das ist etwas worauf Washington
jetzt auch setzt das ist nicht nur der
Westen ist der Putin einschränken muss
sondern das ist jetzt oxiding Ping ist
der im Zweifelsfall sich dazu sich
darauf eingelassen hat dass solche
nukleardrungen nicht akzeptabel sind und
das ist natürlich ein Partner für
Russland und für Wladimir Putin dennoch
viel wichtiger ist als der Westen es ist
klar und trotzdem noch mal zurück
gefragt auf die Situation jetzt welche
Möglichkeiten hat denn der besten jetzt
eigentlich auf diese Eskalationen von
Putin zu reagieren
noch mehr Waffen noch mehr Sanktionen
schärfere Sanktionen die Karten da sind
offensichtlich langsam ausgereizt was
tut man wenn er aus welchen Gründen auch
immer
eskaliert es gibt ehrlich gesagt ein
Dreisatz der seit dem Tag eins des
Krieges gilt und der gilt weiter die
Sanktion werden gebraucht und es wird
auch weitere geben gerade auch nach
einer solchen Katastrophe ist es
offensichtlich dass sie gebraucht werden
und die Europäische Union hat ja immer
geschlossen genau diese Sanktion noch
auf dem Weg gebracht es gilt aber
natürlich auch dass wir jetzt sehr viel
genauer schauen wo werden sie den
unterwandert in der Europäischen Union
teilweise vielleicht auch bei uns in
Deutschland welche Schwierigkeiten gibt
es bei der kompletten Umsetzung die die
die Party haben wir jeden Tag und das
ist notwendig dass wir da auch da dran
bleiben das zweite ist dass man
natürlich der Ukraine beisteht mit
militärischer Hilfe aber eben nicht nur
mit militärische Hilfe gerade jetzt sie
haben ja alle gesehen den
Aufschrei von Präsident selinski wie
langsam tatsächlich ja die humanitäre
Hilfe gerade kommt ich verstehe das und
wir müssen da alle miteinander besser
werden also Europäische Union als Westen
und der der Ukraine das dritte ist
die zahlreichen Kriegsverbrechen
natürlich nicht vergessen werden dürfen
und aufgezeichnet sein müssen und es
sehr klar sein muss wir werden alles
daran setzen dass diejenigen die dafür
verantwortlich sind am Ende aus zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden tun wir das
nicht ist es die Vorbereitung für die
nächste große Ungerechtigkeit die von
derselben Leuten tatsächlich auch raus
und wenn Vladimir Putin dann trotzdem
festlegt dass das was er nicht bekommen
kann dass er das kaputt macht welche
Möglichkeiten dass er das zerstört
welche Möglichkeiten hat da der Westen
noch zu reagieren was tun wir bei einer
weiteren Eskalation
beschränkte Möglichkeiten ich bin auch
wirklich darüber überrascht gewesen wie
wenig die Sanktionen ausgerichtet haben
also ein Freund der gerade einige Tage
in einem Kulturaustausch in in St
Petersburg war sagte die Menschen mit
denen er hat gesprochen hat
wahnsinnig Deutsch freundlich wie immer
schon in Sankt Petersburg
keinerlei aggressive Worte aber hier
auch das Gefühl
Sanktionen wir merken was davon weil die
bei deutsche Luxusautos jetzt einen
kleinen Aufpreis kosten weil die über
die Türkei importiert werden müssen und
das kostet dann da für ein luxusautomat
10 20.000 Euro mehr aber ansonsten
kommen wir mit allem gut zurecht das ist
St Petersburg das ist nicht Russland
aber
trotzdem bin ich erschrocken wenn ich
mir denke wie viel wir uns am Anfang der
Sache von unseren Sanktionen versprochen
haben und die die Geldquellen sind ja
offenbar nicht versiegt im Gegenteil
durch die Gesetze des Öl- und Gasmarktes
die globalen Gesetze des Ölen Gasmarktes
verdient Putin heute möglicherweise mehr
mit seinen fossilen Ressourcen als
früher
da ich bin ein bisschen verzweifelt
darüber dass man mit friedlichen Mitteln
wie Sanktionen so wenig ausbricht
ausrichtet da wird ja immer gesagt Herr
Mölling dass die erst nach einer
bestimmten Zeit wirken und das einem
natürlich äh die Geduld fehlt in einer
konkreten militärischen Situation das
Wirken der Sanktionen abzuwarten aber
noch mal nach Putin gefragt was glauben
sie sind denn Putins nächste Schritte
uns den Ukrainern noch zu wenden und
deren Offensive was glauben sie wird
Putin als nächstes Unternehmen na ich
glaube wir haben es eben schon gehört
seine Handlungsoptionen sind relativ
gering zumindest auf der militärischen
Ebene das ist ja gerade auch der das
Beispiel Stauder alles das was man als
ihre reguläre Krieg Führung bezeichnen
würde ist ja das Eingeständnis dass man
militärisch eben nicht mehr eskalieren
kann das ist glaube ich ganz ganz
wichtig in dem Zusammenhang von daher
geht es glaube ich für ihn zum Zeit ganz
stark darum auch sein Inneres
Machtgefüge weiterhin einigermaßen
stabil zu halten denn je mehr jetzt auch
die Nachrichten das fängt jetzt gerade
erst an über die Offensive nach Moskau
schwappen wird sich jeder überlegen
müssen okay will ich auf der Seite der
Gewinner oder der Verlierer sein ist
das was ich sozusagen erwirtschaftet
habe kann ich das mit Putin noch halten
oder nicht und das ist natürlich ein
Effekt je weiter die Offensive vorank
wir hoffen sie kommt sehr gut voran umso
mehr müssen sie Leute überlegen wie sie
ihre Schäfchen ins Trockene bringen ich
glaube da ist möglicherweise aber da ist
Sabine hat er sicherlich ein besserer
Ansprechpartnerin auch die machbasis
dann irgendwann mal mit einem
Fragezeichen versehen und auch die Frage
wer hält den Kopf dafür hin wenn
gegenüber Putin wenn jetzt die Sachen in
der in der Ukraine mit der Offensive
möglicherweise richtig schief gehen
sie beschreiben uns noch mal vor Adler
was sie wissen ihre Vermutung ist das
vor allen Dingen in der Elite des Landes
der Zorn wächst auf also auf der einen
Seite ist es so dass die kampfreserve
endlich ist auch in Russland also es
gibt jetzt Methoden dass man per SMS
benachrichtigt wird dass man eingezogen
wird das heißt also diese Note überhaupt
Soldaten noch für diesen Dienst
irgendwie zu bekommen ist groß und auf
der anderen Seite gibt es eine enorme
unrein Unmut in der Elite und der wird
daher dass die Elite natürlich sieht in
anderthalb machen schmilzt ihr Vermögen
in einem rasanten Tempo zusammen und so
viel zum zur Wirkung von von Sanktionen
ich glaube gar nicht dass das so langsam
geht und dass die Sanktion nicht wirken
denn das was wir erleben das hören wir
so in ein paar Spitzen von bestimmten
Oligarchen im Ausland im Westen da
werden unverhohlen wirklich richtig
schwere Vorwürfe in Richtung Putin
persönlich geäußert wir haben die
Reichtum schmilzt weil
Bewegungsmöglichkeiten eingeschränkt
sind auf die Konten hat weil die Kinder
nicht mehr im Ausland studieren können
also richtig da wo es dem Olli gar nicht
ein weh tut da kommt er jetzt nicht mehr
an und was aber wirklich das noch
wichtigere ist ist es ist eine ein Kampf
schon jetzt absehbar wer wird diesen
Reichtum mal bekommen also wenn Putin
mal nicht mehr ist und Putin ist
derjenige bei dem der ganze Reichtum
auch persönlich zusammen läuft der
Statthalter hat also timchenko oder
cobaltschuk das sind Leute die sein
riesiges Vermögen verwalten und ihm
persönlich gehört natürlich nichts aber
genau um diese Vermögen wird mal
wirklich schwer gekämpft werden und wir
sehen das jetzt an bestimmten
Entwicklungen zum Beispiel das immer
mehr private Armeen entstehen dass diese
private Armeen auch aus der Deckung
kommen also nicht nur pregorien ist
derjenige der unverhohlen den
Präsidenten
herausfordert der Ihnen ein Opa einen
Vollidioten nennt und noch schlimmere
Sachen und sich mit der Armeeführung
anliegt mit dem Genre mit dem
Verteidigungsminister mit dem
generalstaatschef und so weiter also das
so etwas überhaupt möglich ist in dieser
absolut homogenen Elite die ansonsten so
festgeschlossen weil es wirklich ein
Zeichen dafür
möchte man trotzdem noch mal verstehen
weil es natürlich genauso gut sein dass
diese Scharmützel und diese Kämpfe die
da stattfinden zwischen kadierdorf
pregoschin und Putin und girassimov und
schorgu auf der anderen Seite dass die
inszeniert sind wer darf denn sonst so
den Residenten angreifen und so den
Verteidigungsminister ich glaube auch
das ist das ist etwas ganz Wichtiges das
ist zum einen ganz großes
Ablenkungsmanöver und darin äußert sich
oder artikuliert sich auch der Unmut den
auch die ganz normalen Russen haben dass
da da lässt man jemand Dampfer ab das
macht er nicht auf die Weise auf die sie
es machen würden stellt ja nicht den
Krieg infrage nicht aber er kritisiert
endlich mal er und er kritisiert die
Führung das ist was ganz Neues also
damit lässt er Dampf ab das ist richtig
aber auf der anderen Seite und das
glaube ich es wirklich das was wir sehen
werden in Zukunft es gibt Personen wie
zum Beispiel Andrea
der ganz klar sagt das ist ein
ein alter erfahrener sagen und
Militärexperte der jetzt mittlerweile
auch in Washington sitzt der sagt wir
haben es hiermit einem Bürgerkrieg zu
tun nicht wie 1917 wo die roten und die
weißen gekämpft haben nein so nicht aber
in den Eliten und da geht es tatsächlich
darum dass sich diese Eliten schon jetzt
bewaffnen also es gibt viele private
Armeen es entstehen private Medien das
wichtigste neueste Beispiel ist Gazprom
das prom gründet eine private Armee ja
wofür denn für den sie sagen offiziell
es könnte ja sein dass Ihre
Infrastruktur angegriffen wird die muss
geschützt werden das kann sein aber es
kann auch sein dass sie selbst sich
etwas abgreifen wollen wir wissen es
nicht auf jeden Fall ist es eine ganz
große Gefahr denn es wird so die
Prognose und neue Verteilungskämpfe
geben weil bestimmte Vermögen dieser
jetzt herrschenden Elite möglicherweise
harmlos werden und dann gibt's ganz
viele interessanten die sich dafür
interessieren könnten und die darum auch
kämpfen werden kann man ganz sicher sein
und insofern gibt es da nicht nur die
Gefahr einer Eskalation Entschuldigung
vielleicht nur noch ergänzend dazu zu
der Wirkung der Sanktion ich glaube ein
wichtiger Punkt den man nicht übersehen
sollte ist auch die wachsende russische
Abhängigkeit von China das ist ein ganz
klares Anzeichen dafür dass die
Sanktionen wirken wir sehen jetzt neue
Statistiken im Handel zwischen Russland
und China in dem insbesondere der Import
aus China nach Russland massiv um 75%
angestiegen ist und man noch ganz klar
sieht dass Russland versucht über
Drittländer über Georgien und die Türkei
Sanktionen zu umgehen das ist etwas wo
die Europäische Union tätig werden muss
haben muss ganz genau aber das genau und
das daran zeigt sich eben auch das
Russland sein Öl und sein Gas sehr viel
günstiger verkaufen muss zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt also das früher getan hat dass
die Sanktionen nicht diese Schockwirkung
hatten die man sich erhofft hat aber
doch gewisse Konsequenzen nicht nur in
politisch sondern auch für den
Außenhandel Russlands haben auch welche
Position und neue Rolle die Chinesen da
haben haben wir hier in der Sendung
schon erörtert weil sie natürlich kein
besonders großes Interesse haben dass
Russland zerfällt sondern dass der
entscheidende Grund ist zu versuchen
Putins Macht zu stützen wir müssen und
wollen Herr Mömlingen über die ja also
über die Ukraine und die Veränderungen
auf ukrainischer Seite reden weil
offensichtlich auch die Ukraine in den
letzten Wochen
zu neuen Mitteln greifen und unter
anderem russisches Territorium mit
Drohnen und mit
entsprechenden Angriffen
erobert haben
habe ich das richtig gemacht noch nicht
aber jetzt
Aufnahmen aus der Hand russischer
Freischärler zu sehen
angeblich russische Dörfer und Städte
Belgrad
auch das russische Fernsehen zeigt
Zerstörungen Anwohner sind schockiert
von drei bis sieben Uhr morgens konnten
wir nicht weg beängstigend
die Ukraine bestreitet hier der direkte
Beteiligung der politische Sprecher der
Legion Freiheit Russlands macht aber
klar wen die Gruppe unterstützt
eines unserer taktischen Ziele ist es
russische Truppen zu zwingen von der
Ukraine Front abzuziehen
zeitungsberichten zufolge verwenden die
Freischärler auch nato-waffen aus den
USA Polen oder Belgien einige
Regierungen sind alarmiert
europäische Waffen werden an die Ukraine
unter der Bedingung geliefert dass sie
auf ukrainischen Territorium zum Zweck
der Verteidigung eingesetzt werden
ja also da sind die Ukraine eben auch
auf russischem Gebiet und das geschieht
offensichtlich eben auch in ihrem Namen
ist das schon mehr als der Westen wollte
Herr Müller wir haben es vorhin schon
angedeutet ist es mehr als wir der
Ukraine gestatten wollten
ich hoffe nicht ich glaube und wir
wissen es noch nicht geschlossen man
muss auch sagen wenn das eine rote Linie
wäre dann würde das ja bedeuten dass man
sich automatisch anhand erstens auf den
Rücken bindet und zweitens
Russland gegenüber ganz klar sagt du
kannst deine Infrastruktur denn es geht
hier ja äh nicht um die Häuser die
kaputt gemacht worden sind Beleuchtung
einer der wesentlichen
logistikumschlagplätze
da brauchst du ja gar keine Sorgen
machen nicht an das wäre das völlig
falsch oder man muss die Karten auf dem
Tisch legen und sagen nee alle Optionen
sind möglich keiner wird bis Moskau
gehen das ist völlig hier absurd als
Kriegsziel aber dass man Diener
reinischen Punkte auf dem russischen
Territorium angreift die den Krieg
überhaupt nur möglich machen
äh ja alles andere wäre doch gar nichts
tun Nachschub und Logistik sind legitime
Ziele Henry pur auch das sagt der Westen
von Beginn des Krieges an damit dürfen
auch Waffen russisches Territorium
erreichen aber auch da sterben Menschen
in Belgorod und inkino sterben auch
Zivilisten ist das uns egal und sagen
wir nur wir wollen nur aber noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass das nicht mit
unseren Waffen geschehen soll die
Legitimität ist eine Frage und ja es ist
überhaupt keine Frage dass die Ukraine
auch im Rahmen ihres völkerrechtlich
verbrief rechts auf Selbstverteidigung
auch über die Grenze gehen kann um und
militärische Ziele zugreifen das andere
ist die politische Auseinandersetzung
der gibt es einmal die sehr klare
Aussage auch der vor allem der
amerikanischen Seite und das ist nicht
irgendein Partner im Westen dass das für
sie die völkerrechtliche Grenze zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine die Grenze ist
auch für die Wirkung der der Waffen und
das zweite ist natürlich auch die
wünsche eine Sorge ob wir dann
beispielsweise als Deutschland mit dem
Einsatz unserer Waffen dann auf
russischem Territorium dann quasi
Kriegspartei werden und die Antwort
darauf ist das werden wir nicht das
werden wir auch nicht zulassen wir
werden nicht Kriegspartei dort sein und
Zielinski hat ausgeschlossen dass das
passiert ob er das durchhalten kann weiß
ich nicht aber wir müssen ihn natürlich
bei seinen Worten sehr ernst nehmen und
noch daran messen die Fragen gleich nach
den militärischen Konsequenzen und
schauen da auch noch mal auf eine Karte
um das richtig zu verstehen aber Diana
fix muss in Washington noch mal gefragt
werden es wird von geheimdienstpapieren
berichtet in der Washington Post wieder
die Ukraine habe die Besetzung
russischer Grenzstädte erbogen um einen
Druckmittel gegen Moskau zu haben kann
es da auch einen Comics eine Beziehung
zu geben
tatsächlich sind diese Papiere die
gelegt worden sind da sind
unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche Erwägungen skizziert
die angeblich in der Ukraine diskutiert
worden sind oder nicht diese Papiere
stammen aber auch und aus
unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten teilweise
Monate her so dass man von diesem
Papieren jetzt nicht unbedingt auf die
aktuellen Aktionen der Ukraine schließen
kann tatsächlich ist es aber so dass aus
US-amerikanischer Sicht man deutlich
entspannter geworden ist als in der
Vergangenheit was diese Aktionen angeht
es ist zwar immer noch die rote Linie
dass dafür nicht us-material genutzt
werden soll weil man eben Sorge von
einem eskalationspotential zwischen der
Nato und Russland hat aber weil diese
ukrainischen Aktionen eben ganz klar
taktische Aktionen sind die darauf
abzielen russische Truppen aus dem Osten
abzuziehen abzulenken die darauf
abziehen im Prinzip ein Propaganda Krieg
zu führen die Stimmung in Russland zu
verändern und nicht Aktionen sind die
jetzt tatsächlich darauf abziehen
russisches Territorium zu sortieren oder
irgendetwas in der Art ist das etwas was
als Teil der Kriegsführung akzeptiert
wird und wo auch die Sorge vor einer
Eskalation noch deutlich weniger groß
ist als sie es noch vor einigen Monaten
war das ist interessante Klaus
entschuldige sind ist jetzt dann auch
egal dass da Neonazis dabei sind dass
der polnische Kämpfer dabei sind damit
werden natürlich auch wiederum
erzählen der Russen gestärkt indem man
sagt da sind noch ganz andere am Werk
und das sind
also ich weiß zu wenig über die die die
die Naziszene im im Ukrainisch
russischen Grenzgebiet um das wirklich
beurteilen zu können aber das ist
natürlich ein enormer Schaden an
Reputationen gegenüber der ukrainischen
Führung und das ist natürlich dann auch
schon wieder ein Instrument in der
Debatte also im Grunde
Leute Sabine Adler aber das viel besser
erklären kann aber was ich höre ist eben
sehr schnell dieser nazi-vorwurf dort
belegt werden kann weil es genügend
Zeugnis immer gibt ist es auch in deinen
Augen schon eine Grenzüberschreitung was
da geschieht von ukrainischer Seite im
doppelten Sinne des Wortes die anderen
Grenzüberschreitungen sind glaube ich
kritischer als diese
nazifiguren die da möglicherweise
beweisen da sind glaube wir müssen
einfach noch mal schauen wer da
eigentlich kämpft das sind nicht Ukraine
die da über die Grenze kommen sondern
das sind Russen das sind Neonazi Russen
ja also das offensichtlich in
ukrainischem Auftrag ja zumindest mit
Billigung vielleicht auch mit
Unterstützung und auch Orchestrierung
dass es durchaus möglich aber also dass
die Neonazis nur Ukraine sein können
nach der Lesart des Kremmen das ist
damit auch wiederlegt also natürlich hat
Russland eine riesengroße neonazis-szene
insofern ist das ja auch völlig aber
witzig gewesen eine Begründung dass nun
ausgerechnet die Ukraine einen Hort von
Neonazis und von fasch sein soll aber da
werden da wird auch deutlich da sind
Kräfte unterwegs auch in der in der
russischen Gesellschaft die sich endlich
mal formieren nämlich gegen Putin
Widerstand zu leisten die sieht man ja
sonst weit und breit nicht es gibt
diesen sehr lauten pregorien aber damit
hat sich ja dann auch mit dem Widerstand
die anderen halten einfach den Mund und
gehen oder oder sind in der inneren
Emigration aber es ist rührt sich ja
niemand und jetzt sind diese zwei
Gruppen die mal sagen es gibt sowas wie
Widerstand und wir machen es euch jetzt
mal ein bisschen unbequem und auch liebe
Landsleute auch euch machen das jetzt
mal ein bisschen unbequem denn daneben
anläuft ein großer Krieg den wir hier
Kämpfer mit denen man eigentlich nichts
zu tun haben will die berühmten Soldaten
ohne Abzeichen die gab es 2014 aber das
sind schon mal das waren die von der
anderen Seite das waren die kleinen
grünen Menschen von der anderen Seite
die
2014 auf der Krim also um den Erfolg
dass die Ukraine den Russen das jetzt
jetzt zurückgeben könnten noch mal wie
groß ist der Schaden den sie ihrem
eigenen ihrem eigenen ansehen antun ich
glaube die die roten Linien sind
tatsächlich welche Waffen werden
verwendet und wer kämpft da und wohin
gehen sie welche Ziele greifen sie an
das ist bestimmt das sind die
schwierigen und die müssen auch
eingehalten werden was aber auch sieht
an diesen Gruppen ist eben dass dieses
ganze Gebilde Russland wo alles unter
dem Deckel gehalten wird wo wirklich mit
einer mit diktatorischen Methoden anders
kann man es ja gar nicht mehr sagen für
Ruhe besorgt wird das ist der brodelt
unter dieser Decke und das wird dann
eben doch ab und zu mal sichtbar und
deutlich
interessant noch mal auch nach dem
Protest zu fragen die Belgier
protestieren Herr Kirby protestiert
können wir auch Frau fix gleich noch mal
sagen deutlich verdammt deutlich zum
Ausdruck gebracht dass das nicht mit
unseren Waffen geschehen soll sagt der
spreche das nationalen Sicherheitsrates
in den USA wie echt ist dann diese
Empörung muss man ja fragen
das finde ich schwer einzuschätzen
einfach weil wir jetzt nicht wissen ob
das systematisch passiert ist ob man das
ganz bewusstlos hochgezogen hat weil es
ja eine Geschichte ist die man jetzt
erzählen kann ne also wie weit wir im
Grunde genommen auch jetzt selber eine
Geschichte draus machen die andere uns
hingehalten haben und darüber natürlich
so ein bisschen den Weg darauf verlieren
was passiert da eigentlich
wenn das diese Nadelstiche und die
Ablenkungen sind für die große Offensive
der Ukraine auf die alle lange gewartet
haben jetzt der Mölling versuchen wir zu
verstehen was sie wissen
es soll die Offensive begonnen haben an
drei neuralgischen Punkten wie schätzen
Sie das ein wie sehr ist das schon eine
offensive Offensive und nicht mehr nur
ein langsames hinrollen der Panzer
Fifty Shades of Offensive ja genau ich
glaube das ist total schwer das zu sagen
sie gibt es und die Serie die Offensive
da natürlich sieht man ein starkes
Ansteigen von militärischen Aktivitäten
seit mehreren Tagen jetzt auch
offensichtlich noch mal sozusagen mehr
dass man versucht
sich noch stärker auch an die russischen
Stellung heranzuwagen das ist sicherlich
noch nicht der die hauptoffensive also
die hauptkampfkräfte die da jetzt
reingehen ist immer noch der Versuch
wahrscheinlich jetzt aber mit sozusagen
direktem Kontakt mit dem Gegner
rauszufinden wo geht denn hier was und
ich glaube da muss man immer
unterscheiden zwischen das ist geplant
und da ergibt sich eine Möglichkeit die
nutze ich jetzt auch noch mit
möglicherweise
das kann ich aber möglicherweise gar
nicht durchhalten wir haben eine Karte
dazu vorbereitet damit man noch mal
versteht wo die Ukraine eigentlich
diesen Landweg zur Krim beschneiden
wollen und zwischen die Ost und die
Südflanke der russischen Besatzer wollen
da kann man das noch mal ganz gut
erklären und erkennen und der kürzeste
viel zum Meer wäre eben unterhalb von
bachmut
also da ein bisschen südlicher unter dem
beschraffierten wo würden wo könnten sie
wissen oder wo vermuten sie sind jetzt
diese drei ersten Durchbrüche also dass
das immer noch ganz klassisch sehen ist
sein rund um bachmut wird weiter
gekämpft also auch die Idee bartmut wäre
gefallen das war eine Momentaufnahme in
dem Augenblick in Russland ist
eingenommen hatte waren ukrainische
unterwegs haben ihrerseiten eine
angefangene Klammer zu versuchen darum
zu legen also da geht's weiter das ist
aber sicherlich nicht die Hauptaktivität
wir sehen dann werden ja
etwas östlicher gibt es zwei Stellen an
den zurzeit stärkere Aktivitäten
tatsächlich stattfinden
und da ist auch der man kann so ganz
kleinen sehen da unten gibt so ein ganz
kleinen Zipfel der wahrscheinlich
kürzeste Weg in Kilometer von der von
der Front bis runter ans also schon mehr
ob der kürzeste immer der einfachste ist
ist dahingestellt aber hier versucht
Zwischenzeit erstmal zu testen und damit
auch das Thema ich sag mal etwas erlaubt
links liegen zu lassen keiner will sich
an dem Thema zu jetzigen Zeitpunkt
wirklich verkämpfen sondern hier geht es
erstmal darum zu gucken ist es das
können wir hier möglicherweise durch
und ansonsten muss man sich vorstellen
die Ukraine wird nicht einen Plan haben
sie werden mehrere haben und entlang des
Widerstandes abschätzen wie sie
reagieren was aber auch noch mit dazu
gehört letzter Satz es wird jetzt
Verluste geben wir werden jetzt auch
westliches kampfmaterial sehen das
kaputt geht weil das ist ja das wäre
unsauberei ja und auch überhaupt nicht
in Einklang mit dem was er das ganze
letzte Jahr gesehen haben das ist eine
bittere Material ist das ist unschöne
Bilder geben wird und das dann ein
Leopard 2 nicht eingefeckter Traktor ist
oder besser gesagt eigentlich ein
Traktor ist und man denkt es sei ein
leer sein es werden tatsächlich auch
Menschen und Material weiter wie ohnehin
in jedem grausamen Krieg zu Schaden
kommen was sich die Ukraine setzt Wochen
wünschen
werden Sie jetzt von den Briten bekommen
nämlich die Storm shadows und es gibt
nicht wenige Militärexperten die sagen
dass die tatsächlich einen Unterschied
machen um die Ukraine nicht mehr nur
defensiv sondern offensiv offensiv sein
zu lassen warum sind es bisher nur die
Briten wo sind die Jets der
US-Amerikaner was können die Deutschen
dazu beitragen ist die berühmte Frage
auch da gibt es Grundsätze die wir vom
Tag eins an mit den Ukrainern
abgesprochen haben wir wollen natürlich
helfen wo es nötig und möglich ist und
das im Verbund und bei den Panzern ist
die Frage wann kommen
wir sowieso nicht aber die das verbunden
ist
Entschuldigung bei dem Panzern gab es ja
eine Diskussion auch innerhalb der
Koalition über die Geschwindigkeit und
jetzt haben wir das gelöst bei der Frage
der der Kampfjet ist es schon Stückchen
anders weil das technologisch natürlich
deutlich kompliziert ist weil die
Ausbildungszeiten deutlich länger sind
und weil das natürlich natürlich auch
der
letzte Baustein ist einer Integration
der Ukraine dauerhaft in
die westlichen Hemisphäre rein und
militärisch Weg aus dem ehemaligen
sowjet-bereich und das ist ja auch eine
der zentralen Gründe strategische Art
warum du keine genau das will und
dementsprechend ist das etwas was man
diskutieren muss und nur noch tut und
das wird in der NATO auch
nicht jetzt ausgeschlossen und niemand
drückt das weg aber wie gesagt
Deutschland ist da jetzt nicht irgendwie
im Fahrersitz dieser Diskussion weil wir
einfach selbst die Materialien dafür gar
nicht haben und dementsprechend
diskutieren wir das sehr Gespräch und
und Diskussionen Ergebnis offen
miteinander ich glaube dass was die
Briten gemacht haben eben auch im ganzen
Schub gegeben hat schauen wir mal so und
dann ist es eher wieder eine Frage auch
an die Kollegen in Washington die
anderen fix warum sind die BR Iten da
noch alleine warum braucht es so lange
eh eben auch diese
kurzstreckenwaffen die weiterreichen und
die die Ukraine bräuchten um diesen
Landgang zu Grimmen tatsächlich auch
abzuschützen und die Krim gegebenenfalls
eben wenigstens auf die Art und Weise
zurückzuholen nicht militärisch zu
erobern aber ihre weitere Versorgung
durch die Russen zu unterminieren warum
stellen wir dafür den Ukrainern diese
Waffen nicht zur Verfügung
ja tatsächlich ist die Situation und den
USA so dass hier während es die
attackens diese kurzschriften Raketen
mit Reichweite bis 300 km die der
Ukraine helfen würden die beiden
Administration ist auch unter Druck vom
Kongress diese zu liefern es wird jedoch
spekuliert dass die USA selber nicht
genug davon haben als dass sie diese an
die Ukraine abgeben wollen und deswegen
eben den dritten signalisiert haben aber
ihr könnt durchaus eure storm-shadows
geben es gab eine Anfrage in Deutschland
die Taurus zu schicken von deutscher
Seite dem hat sich Deutschland bisher
verweigert und es zeigt auch dass wir
dort eine Dynamik haben die eigentlich
seit Beginn da ist das Deutschland immer
genau das tut was die Amerikaner tun das
wahrscheinlich unglücklichen
panzerdebatte so dass die Briten ihre
Panzer angeboten haben und Deutschland
aber gewartet hat das Kanzleramt
gewartet hat bis die Amerikaner grünes
Licht gegeben haben also da gibt es eine
enge einige würden sagen Deutschland
und dann 10 Minuten das hat tatsächlich
für extrem große Verärgerung gesorgt ja
und nun ist natürlich die viel
wichtigere Entscheidung glauben sie dass
dieser Prozess auch so ausgeht wie alle
anderen Prozesse dass das immer ewig
dauert und das am Ende aber die
US-Amerikaner und die Deutschen sich
unterhaken und das dann der Westen auch
das liefert was die Ukraine brauchen
oder glauben Sie genau da ist diese
berühmte Wegscheide und genau da ist die
berühmte militärische Grenze
also ich glaube tatsächlich dass die F
16 die Kampfflugzeuge dass das ein
wichtiger Schritt war die das Training
findet ihr statt und das ist auch etwas
wo die USA mitgegangen sind nachdem auch
da wieder die Briten den ersten Schritt
gemacht haben also wir sind tatsächlich
das eine der wenigen europäischen
Nationen die Briten hier durchaus eine
Führungsrolle übernehmen und ich glaube
wenn es militärisch notwendig ist und
das ist immer das Mantra das Pentagons
hier werden auch irgendwann attackens
wieder diskutiert werden vor allem auch
wenn der Druck aus dem Kongress da ist
die Frage ist ein bisschen dass nach
hinten hin mit Blick auf die
US-amerikanischen Präsidentschaftswahlen
nächstes Jahr natürlich gar nicht mehr
so viel Zeit ist und auch innerhalb der
innerhalb sozusagen das Budgets was die
USA zur Verfügung haben die Rechnung
eigentlich ist das dieses Budget für die
Ukraine noch ungefähr bis zum Sommer
oder zum Herbst reicht und dann man
zurück zum Kongress muss und weitere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine um weitere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine bitten
muss und die Sorge ist das da die
Republikaner insbeson oder die radikalen
Republikaner im Repräsentantenhaus sich
quer stellen werden das heißt die
Amerikaner schauen auch ganz genau
welche Dinge kosten viel und mit welchen
Dingen die vielleicht weniger kosten
kann man im Moment mehr erreichen in der
Ukraine weil sie auch unter
innenpolitischen Druck stehen ein Grund
warum sie möchten dass die Ukraine
erfolgreich sind mit der gegen Offensive
dieses Jahr weil wir nächstes Jahr in
den US-amerikanischen
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf reinkommen und
auch das war schon Thema bei uns das hat
den logischen Schluss Klaus Kleber dass
sich Putin jetzt einfach zurücklehnt und
bis zum November 2024 wartet weil er
davon ausgehen kann dass dem Westen bis
dahin die Luft ausgegangen ist
zurücklegen wird er sich ganz sicher
nicht ähm und wenn Sabine Adler Recht
hat was sie fast immer hat ist und
tatsächlich auch so ein
zerbröselungsprozess in seinem eigenen
Regime beginnt kann er nicht mehr davon
ausgehen dass die Zeit im reicht bis
November 2024 ist noch eine ganz schön
lange und möglicherweise geht dieser
Zerfallsprozess der nach russischen
erfolgen giert im Land jetzt sehr viel
schneller als die die amerikanische
Politik die ja auch auf einem sehr
unglücklichen Weg ist in dieser Hinsicht
die nächsten Monate werden schwierig die
nächsten 18 und dennoch wieder ganz
konkret nach der Ukraine also James
David es war bei uns in der Sendung und
sagte es ist entscheidend diese
Schwachstelle der Ukraine und die ist im
Himmel und nicht am Boden dass die
aufgehoben wird durch den besten und die
brauchen unsere Unterstützung da und der
Krieg ist in einem also die Krim ist
eine entscheidende Halbinsel um die
Ukraine zu einem friedlichen souveränen
Land zu machen wenn das alles so ist
warum tun wir es dann nicht gibt es
immer noch dieses Misstrauen gegenüber
der Ukraine
ich glaube das wirklich gehört
müssen einfach sehen das dauert jetzt
sehr lange ja und wir reden jetzt gerade
über die Offensive und vielleicht 2024
wir befinden uns ja eigentlich in einem
auch hier in einem sehr flüssigen
Übergang zwischen etwas was jetzt noch
Krieg ist und wo es irgendwann mal wo
wir jetzt schon anfangen müssen darüber
nachzudenken wie die Ukraine in das
westliche Verteidigungssystem integriert
wird aber frühzeitig auch gesagt ne auch
beim Thema Munition da fing das schon an
da müssen wir frühzeitig drüber
nachdenken einfach weil die ab das
abschützen der der Ukraine in einem
späteren hoffentlich Friedrich den
Zustand das muss jetzt geplant
angefangen werden das ist bei dem
Piloten genauso die Grundausbildung für
Piloten dass man viele Sachen weg dauert
sicherlich länger als dieses Jahr selbst
wenn die schon fliegen können das heißt
die Maschinen die sind nicht für diese
Offensive gedacht vielleicht auch gar
nicht mehr für die nächste
offensichtlich wahrscheinlich
gedacht um möglicherweise schon gedacht
für die für die Absicherung der Ukraine
in einem fragilen Waffenstillstand
Friedenszustand denn darüber müssen wir
jetzt nachdenken sonst fallen wir immer
hinten runter zurzeit ist die Idee das
ist jetzt die Offensive und die beendet
alles nein das ist nicht wahr das wird
nicht so sein es werden ganz viele
einzelne offensiven sein es wird sehr
lange dauern haben wir bis jetzt
erfahren und gehört von den
Militärexperten es wird auf gar keinen
Fall so sein wie im Sommer des letzten
Jahres da sagen sie so muss man sich das
vorstellen das kann auch wieder dieses
Hin und Her diesen Stellungskrieg also
dahin kann das auch wieder zurückkehren
das kann immer sein ne also Krieg ist
Chaos man kann nie richtig wissen wie es
ausgeht deswegen versucht man bevor man
sozusagen aufeinander trifft ganz viel
vorzubereiten bis das Chaos anfängt zu
wirken aber wir müssen vor allem daran
denken es wird nur Offensive 20 24 und
vielleicht 20 25 geben zur Zeit hat der
Kalender dieses Krieges offensichtlich
nur bis 2023 geworden das wäre eine sehr
blinde Voraussicht das würde Putin in
die Hände spielen wenn wir nur so weit
geht es gibt politischen Kalender der
dagegen geht was aber auch bedeutet dann
werden die Europäer mehr Aufgabe
übernehmen
die Frage bleibt ja wie er das
generieren kann und das ist ja irgendwie
die hauptbaustelle die Frage wenn ich es
richtig verstehe auf der russischen
Seite ist ja nicht nur das Geld was
knapp wird sondern vor allem wo kriegen
sie noch die Leute hin die gerade auch
die sie als Kanonenfutter da in ins Feld
geschickt haben das Beispiel der SMS die
die herum gehen weil man nicht mehr weiß
wie man die Leute her kriegen soll und
auch keine keine Leute hat ihre
losziehen
belegt dafür und deshalb ist es richtig
was sie sagen wir sollten nicht zu tun
als hätten wir festen Fahrplan und
sollten nicht so tun als wäre es jetzt
in sechs Monaten vorbei es ist ein
Geduldspiel auch aber zunehmend ist es
sichtbar dass es nicht ewig auf der das
ist nicht ewig muss jetzt meine Militär
sozusagen Durchhaltekraft gibt der
durchhaltefähigkeiten gibt auf der
russischen Seite aber ich finde die
schlechte Nachricht ist wenn man sich
meine Studie anguckt die zwei
Amerikanerinnen gemacht haben die haben
sich angeschaut seit 1946 das Verhältnis
von Diktaturen und kriegen und die
schlechte Nachricht aber ist dass Kriege
umso länger dauern wenn Sie von einer
Diktatur geführt werden das heißt also
wir haben es mit einer Diktatur zu tun
sieht überhaupt nicht aus als würde
Putin irgendwie Einlenken ich glaube
auch dass das die Prognose leider die
ist dass es lange dauert das ist lange
dauert und bis dahin
was vielleicht
genau das nächste Datum was vielleicht
relevant ist und zwar nicht aus dem
Blick verlieren sollte ist der NATO
Gipfel den willius denn da zeichnet sich
bereits der nächste Streitpunkt ab
innerhalb der Allianz nämlich das
Deutschland und die USA sehr
zurückhaltend sind bei der Frage soll
mal der Ukraine die Nation anbieten oder
nicht und andere Länder sagen wenn wir
das jetzt nicht tun ist es schon wieder
zu spät so wie es damals zu spät weil
wir müssen diese Perspektive eröffnen
und müssen endlich diese Grauzone in der
die Ukraine sich befindet die Putin
immer wieder dazu verleitet die Ukraine
anzugreifen die Ukraine in Frage zu
stellen die müssen wir endlich beenden
und der Ukraine eine klare klare Heimat
geben in der EU und in der NATO und
genau das ist ein tiefer Twist der auch
hier schon diskutiert wurde und nicht
aufzulösen ist weil in der Zeit des
Krieges kann die Ukraine sowieso nicht
aufgenommen werden in die Nato und wie
man anschließend mit ihr verfärbt ohne
Putin gleich einen Hinweis zu geben dann
übrigens den Krieg zu verlängern damit
das auf gar keinen Fall geschieht ist ja
schon ein Dilemma in sich wenn man jetzt
sagt nach dem Krieg findet eine Aufnahme
der Ukraine in die NATO statt hat man
Putin signalisiert diesen Krieg
möglichst nicht enden zu lassen ist das
schon ein hinlänglich geschriebenes also
wenn man das wenn man mit in der Ukraine
mit Menschen spricht dann wird einem
klar das selenski seinem eigenen Volk
ähm ein Frieden oder ein
Waffenstillstand oder gar irgendeinen
packt mit Russland nicht verkaufen kann
wenn nicht endlich bessere
Sicherheitsgarantien
vorliegen die haben zwei Verträge von
Russland unterschrieben hinter sich ne
also das Budapester Protokoll wurde ja
von der Russland akzeptiert und die und
die Metzger Abkommen bedeuten auch auf
keinen Fall Angriff auf die Ukraine
Papier danke schön das hatten die das
kann kein silenski seinem Volk klar
machen das ist ein schönes neues Papier
mit zwei Unterschriften mehr gibt und
jetzt diesmal sind wir sicher also für
ihn ist das ein unbedingt muss dass
diese NATO Option geöffnet wird und da
wird auch die EU was immer so
hingehalten wird als so eine kleine
Zwischenlösung dann bist Du ja schon
fast eine tot also sind schon mal u mit
drin und das wird ganz bestimmt gut äh
die Union wird dieser Art er braucht
eine Verteidigungsunion und
dafür werden im Moment auch viel zu
große Opfer gebracht also wenn er nicht
in einer verzweifelten Lage ist was ja
auch immer noch passieren kann eher
selenski in einen nicht mehr
verzweiflage ist wird er keine
Unterschrift leisten unter was was
weniger kommt man sofort wieder an
Kissinger ähm in NATO Mitglied Ukraine
aber Gebietsabtretungen ist das worauf
es dann am Ende hinausliefere der
der der gesamte Krieg ist darüber ob
über die Frage ob die Ukraine souveränes
Land ist und wenn wir das Aufgeben dann
dann ist hat Russland gewonnen
souveränes Land heißt aber dass die
Ukraine selbst entscheiden was mit ihrem
Territorium passiert ja
sowieso nicht selbst entscheiden weil
sie sehr von unserem Engagement abhängt
ob das können sie trotzdem entscheiden
hier entscheiden über unser Engagement
richtig Ukraine entscheidend
wir machen es ja auch weil es um unsere
Sicherheit geht ich glaube das ist in
dem Zusammenhang noch ganz wichtig
deswegen ist diese nato-geschichte auch
nicht nicht in Almosen sondern es ist
tatsächlich unsere Sicherheit um die es
geht und am Ende ist die NATO eine
politische Gemeinschaft auch wenn es ein
Vertrag gibt wenn alle 31 die Hand heben
dann ist die Ukraine in der NATO egal
was man früher mal als Prinzipien
beschlossen hat denn das steht so wenn
ich mich recht im Sinne im NATO-Vertrag
selbst nicht drin ist es interessant ich
hätte ihn nicht gedacht dass die Runde
man sich jetzt darauf verständigt dass
es durchaus die Möglichkeit gibt ein
gewisses Deutschland wurde auch mal
aufgenommen in die NATO ohne dass das
gesicherte Grenzen hatte man musste noch
nicht mal welche Grenze das sein soll
die Kehrseite ist ja auch welche Art von
Sicherheitsgarantien müssen da zusammen
verhandelt werden ist das nicht so
langwierig nicht so umständlich so wenig
überzeugend denn die wenn wir uns ja zu
Anfang des Kriege sehr die einfachste
Lösung auf wir und es wäre eine echte
Sicherheitsgarantie während bei meinem
bei dieser externen Sicherheitsgarantie
dann braucht man die die
Chinesen drin die innen drin
wahrscheinlich in Amerika noch mit dabei
und immer das alles verhandelt hat ist
irgendwie ja wenn nur wenigstens zwei
überhaupt nicht gut finden
und die mit denen können wir das gerade
nicht diskutieren ich denke das ist
herzlich für diese Runde und bitte
diesen irgendwie unerschreckend oder
abgesagt zu entschuldigen wir sehen uns
nächsten Donnerstag wieder wenn Sie
mögen eine herzlichen Dank für 60
Minuten an diesem Abend wenn Sie mögen
nächste Woche 22:15 Uhr gleiche Stelle
gleiche Welle bei Markus Lanz sitzt
jetzt unter anderem Saskia eskind und
sie kommen hoffentlich alle gut durch
diesen Abend und durch die kommenden
Tage tschüss vielen Dank
[Musik]